let's start off for the beginning I had
no idea still a buzz at my comedy set I
mean I nailed it I gave these people a
memory some people think that doing prop
comedy pulling stuff out of a trunk well
might be run the risk of being a little
hacky cheesy do you don't I'm saying
where you were all worried about doing
prop comedy you know and being compared
to people like a carrot top or something
like that whose character I'm not
familiar carrot tops a very famous
comedian who does property comedy yes
prop comedy we don't call it property
company we call it prop comedy and you
take it out of a trunk in wood why would
you shorten property to prop just called
property comedy okay all right because
that was a trunk full of my personal
effects okay and I turned it into comedy
gold your property if you will I keep a
small mouse in a tiny house that I call
a pad yeah a house is a pad so it's a
mouse pad it's a mouse pad and when I
saw that I was like write it down put it
in the trunk for your property comments
okay
I just happen to have a Mercedes Benz
steering wheel attached to a toilet seat
in my garage and I was looking at it for
like two years I'm like this has gotta
be a joke in here don't throw it out
don't throw it out right yeah and then
Bing Bing yeah like Christmas morning
this Christmas morning
so do you aim to me do you while I was
sitting on the toilet oh okay on that
toilet yeah well that toilet seat okay
all right didn't need to know it was an
actual toilet seat that you used but I
guess that's true so you're you're out
there doing comedy now you're out there
now doing comedy for the last three
weeks yeah and this was my best show by
far yes thank you I really appreciate
such a supportive lovely crap you ever
had a crowd that wasn't that supportive
to your comedy uh well out of the twenty
shows I've done 17 have not been
supportive wait a minute 17 out of 20 17
17 shows have been miserable I was a
place called the San Juan Depot down in
San Juan Capistrano and the crowd
literally walked out really does anyone
ever get violent at your shows they
violent with each other I gave them two
such they hated my comedy so much they
started beating each other really I know
you can't explain it
so Friday's is Don Rickles once said
either leave him laughing or leave him
fighting I don't I knew Don Rickles
comedy well I don't believe he ever said
that it's gonna be honest with your on
and Elaine may have you listened to the
records they know it's Mike Nichols and
Elaine May it's Mike Nichols in Elaine
May and Don Rickles has Don Rickles no
Don Rickles Mike Nichols and Elaine May
okay
back together again all right
I don't think I don't think for someone
who's doing comedy yeah you don't seem
to know a lot about of the game we're
all students with every day you learn if
you don't you die okay so okay you yeah
sorry I guess I go I'm sorry
no you should be sorry well I am sorry I
apologize okay let's put that behind him
okay every day you got to learn
something yeah I tried to learn one new
thing a day Oh what did you learn today
how to peel a cucumber in my kitchen
this morning um I wanted a thought I
wanted to make a cucumber sandwich and I
did not know how to peel the cucumber so
I went on my computer my old Commodore
64 and typed in peel a cucumber so I got
a small I got a small wood axe
I got a wood axe wood axe took it in the
garage I put into a vise what and I
cleave to the cucumber oh into
four-quadrant okay what website was this
in I used tweezers okay and a little bit
of about 120 grit sandpaper and I sanded
down the skin gently sounded down the
skin and then I dipped them very
carefully an ammonium chloride a
solution of ammonium chloride ammonium
chloride and motor oil and it peeled the
skin off do you have a vegetable peeler
in your kitchen that's what I need to
get is yeah
no I don't obviously no you should get
one tomorrow that would be the thing I
learned tomorrow
where'd it by adventure we got to learn
one new thing of it what do you think a
day well I'm thrilled that you've joined
us in the comedy community we comedians
welcome you are you a comedian right no
no no no relax
no but do you consider yourself more a
talk show host
I think of myself as a you know an
affable chap who leans into in the
comedy territory what would you say
Eddie yeah I'm not I'm not saying
anything yeah okay yeah yeah I got a
live with him yes you're agnostic I am
yes all right I don't know what that
word yeah yeah